collide stars Nicholas Hoult Felicity
Jones Anthony Hopkins and Ben Kingsley
and is the story of a man who's just
kind of hanging out in Cologne Germany
he doesn't really have any friends and
his family sucks so he's just kind of
you know dealing drugs and then he meets
Felicity Jones at a bar and then there's
like a montage where they fall in love
it's about a minute and a half long and
it goes over the course of about a month
and we learned that they love each other
now but she's kind of sick so he has to
get money for an operation so we've got
to go do the drug thing again but it
goes wrong and now he's running around
and it's dangerous and there's people
chasing him look I wouldn't saw this
movie I had absolutely no idea what it
was about it was coming out this weekend
and I love movies I love talking about
movies and so I like a lot of the stars
in this movie in fact the main four
leads in this movie I like all of them
so I was like all right you know at
least we have that I went to this film
not even knowing the plot I had no idea
what it was about it's really bad this
movie came out last year in a ton of
countries and it's just now coming out
in America so that should really tell
you everything you need to know from the
opening scene alone I was very concerned
about the amount of ADR that was in the
film quite a bit of audio dubbing quite
a bit and it continues throughout the
entire film almost all of felicity jones
performance sounds as if it's from
someone else it barely even sounds like
her it probably is I mean she's a big
enough star now she's in fucking row one
so I mean I don't think they would hire
another actress to do her voice but mad
ADR the camera will often drift in the
middle of a close-up to other things in
the background away from the actors
faces direction like that is filled
throughout this entire movie I have no
idea what people were thinking I have
absolutely no clue why Nicholas Hoult
Felicity Jones Anthony Hopkins and Ben
Kingsley are in this film especially
Felicity Jones her character is awful
she's someone who just is sick
and then she becomes a damsel in
distress that's the entire purpose of
her character Nicholas Hoult has to run
around and try to get this money for her
to have some operation and a lot of
people are chasing after him and it
leads to a few okay chase sequences
that's about the best this movie has to
offer there's some okay car chase scenes
that aren't complete shit there are some
good things you can glean from this
movie though particularly Ben Kingsley's
character he's fairly embarrassing in
this movie but that being said when you
walk into a room and it's Ben Kingsley
with this insane accent just sitting on
a pile of women watching the John
Travolta and Jamie Lee Curtis aerobics
movie called perfect I don't know what
else you could possibly ask for in there
where I always know what is it too
dangerous
what kind of God does that I mean Ben
Kingsley has an entire monologue
dedicated to how much he adores Burt
Reynolds he actually says you could take
a match and strike it on Burt Reynolds
body Anthony Hopkins has a sequence
where he imitates Sylvester Stallone so
there's that I really am actually kind
of blown away by this film because in
one part it's trying to be a
stereotypical action film with car
chases and running then it's trying to
be a romantic film where you really care
about this couple despite the fact that
the entire film emotional motivation is
told in a 1 and a half minute montage
that's barely good enough to set up a
romance in a short film let alone a
feature film and then you have Ben
Kingsley and Anthony Hopkins and
incredibly embarrassing performances
this film is kind of an amalgamation of
awesome it's just all the types of
awesome I don't think they were going
for the film cares so little to set up
the central romance that we have
expositional dialogue like you know
we've been seeing each other everyday
for a month now
Carla construe maybe we should move in
together in regards to the action
sequence part of the film it takes about
an hour before we actually get an action
scene that's worth
damn and it's okay it's that typical
pg-13 action editing where things are
cut away from very quickly and there's
some really awful incomprehensible CGI
car crashes at one point but there is a
pretty impressive sequence on the
Autobahn in fact the original title of
this movie was actually Autobahn which
leads me to believe that the entire
reason they made this movie was to have
a big epic car chase on the Autobahn
because you can go really fast I mean
that's really the only thing I can think
of that would explain why this movie got
made and no one in this movie gives a
shit about security cameras Anthony
Hopkins character is supposed to be an
upstanding member of society who's never
been caught in the drug trade which is
what he's actually involved in and
there's no proof of it despite the fact
that people are kind of like you know
maybe this is the thing you learn that
towards again where there's this cop
who's like yeah we can't bring this guy
down but for whatever reason he's doing
all this shit in front of security
cameras at gas stations and other places
throughout the entire film I mean when
you got the guy on film shooting up a
gas station I would say that's fairly
incriminating but you know that's just
me
this film had no idea what to focus on
it's trying to be a romance is trying to
be an action movie it's trying to be a
film with really awkward dialogue that
seems completely out of place and too
hilariously bad performances by Hopkins
and Kingsley two incredible actors that
I highly admire and I have no idea what
they're doing here I feel like they're
both just so far along in their careers
they're just like whatever fuck it we're
going to take a roll and have some fun I
guess because that's really the only
thing I can think to explain what
they're doing in this film collide is an
awful awful movie with one pretty cool
car chase on the Autobahn I'm going to
give it a d-minus also I do want to let
you know that my promotion with Adam
tickets is still going on if you use my
name Chris and download that app you can
get $5 off your order for the rest of
the entire year which is incredible they
have so many amazing perks on this app
you can set up a group to go to a film
and have everyone paced separately which
completely gets rid of the whole iou
thing which as we all know sucks you can
also pay for concessions ahead of time
so you can skip the line it's a
very very cool app for reserving movie
tickets and having everything just go a
lot smoother
so please do download atom tickets
that's ATO M you can use it on your
Android or your iPhone and use my name
Chris as the coupon code and get five
dollars off your order for the rest of
the year guys thank you so much as
always for watching I greatly appreciate
it and as always if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Applause]
[Music]